Linda was very religious you know that  Vulcan greeting yeah of the the V sign  yeah that comes from a Jewish ritual  that's a really yeah oh you didn't know  that now I'm not sure Jim's aglet in  fact making this huh no no Leonard is a  very inventive creative activity but we  and he comes up with ideas on the set  and he was a greeting an alien  ambassador on board the ship and he said  we need something some form of  salutation a handshake is not the way to  do it and he said what about this and he  demonstrated this this did that be right  and the director said that's great  that's wonderful and he said this is a  part of a Jewish ritual I know and no  yeah Benji's telling me he knows what  that is he says it's called the Cohan  blessing good good is that what it's  called yeah kollene that's what he says  cocaine well now I've added another word  to my vocabulary